The joe rogan experience,
you gave it an eight.
I think garage bands pretty amazing too.
The,
the program where you can pretty much make your own song pretty easily.
Don't they have programs like that for your phone now?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
There was,
I don't know if we ever talked about it.
There was this,
back in the day in my space,
somebody linked,
uh,
one of my songs on their myspace page and like stole it from my web host.
And so like when you went to their myspace page,
it automatically played a song for myself.
So I,
what I did is I took that file,
took it down,
and then made up a quick song and garage band about like,
ah,
Stacy from Hollywood,
California.
I want you to suck my Dick and made a whole song just about how I wanted to fuck
this girl and stuff like that.
And I replaced that song,
that file,
what the original file so that when people went to her myspace page,
it just started playing that song.
Yeah.
I just love it.
I don't know how that,
why even thought about that,
but it's pretty funny video.
It's funny when you think that with a hot linking and speaking of my space,
I think the yesterday what officially really just downsize.
They shut off Germany,
my space,
Germany is dead.
Somebody tweeted me,
my space cut all their employees like three months ago.
Like half of their employees,
they cut Jordan and they just did it again.
Jordy.
Yeah,
Jordy was rich and now you're lucky to,
you know he's worth comedy central but they use working memory.
We would come.
My sweets comedy was thriving.
I'm sure you did one of those secret shows.
I do want a secret shows.
I'm thinking about deleting my mind space live on the air.
What do you think do it if they're going to cut,
show and ruin.
You know,
it's funny how we did it with a,
I think,
I forget who we did it with,
like Jason Tebow or something like that.
Somebody deleted their,
my space the other day live on air a on the old one podcast.
Christ.
I can't even come up with one original idea,
but watch how many steps it is.
It's pretty hilarious.
It was Ari.
Ari did it and it was like three steps.
Like they make it really hard.
Like are you sure you
still have people on it trying to talk to you?
Very,
very,
very few.
Almost all of it is completely dead as well.
You want to go into my mind that also will duel?
Yeah,
dual one.
I paid some money to have my tricked out too at one point.
Yeah.
Did you have glitter tags?
I don't know.
It seems like you would probably cause a failure.
I'm just,
I can even say it.
So if you want to delete your my space now too,
and we could have a double my space and I'm going to keep mine hide this
motherfucker.
It's not easy.
I don't even know where to go.
Um,
here,
I'll tell you guys where to go.
Hold on.
Um,
more.
Delete my space.
I don't even know if I know my family that it's time to let it go.
You know what I mean?
It's like the girl that you dated 10 years ago and his phone number still in
your book.
Throw that shit out,
son.
Moldovan it's in your book.
Listen to me.
Your book,
who is a phone book anymore?
Phone books are worth nothing.
Fuck you.
And your phone book.
What?
I to write it on paper.
Like some caveman.
The good for standing on.
Yeah.
Why don't you just give me some burnt sticks and I'll use it to carve the
fucking numbers on a rock.
How did delete,
how did he do it?
And now I can't even,
can't even figure it out.
Oh,
here you go.
There you go.
All right.
If you decided to delete my space,
what you do is more,
um,
you go to my account and then,
uh,
where's my account?
It's under more my stuff.
My stuff.
Account settings right here.
Account settings.
And then you go,
it looks different.
I have to give them that.
Yeah,
it looks different.
It doesn't lie.
Logo this case,
should we give him a chance now that they redesigned everything?
Damn Owl.
We committed to this,
bro.
We've committed to this man.
We're going to show us everything in here.
It looks good.
Hey look,
white details.
Remember the,
I constantly had those horrible fucking ads.
Full account.
Here we go.
I don't want to cancel.
She was smiley face or something.
I said Brian is not just cancel account.
Right?
It's deleted.
I want to delete.
No,
you want to cancel account?
Where's it?
Yep.
Am canceling.
Yeah,
we're sorry.
You want to leave,
please let us know why to say,
cause you can really help us improve my space.
It is not an,
it's over bitch option has board spam,
privacy and email.
I'm going to go with spam.
That's the one thing that annoyed him.
Where is it Joe?
Where's the cancer council account?
Under settings.
Under settings go under account settings and privacy
settings and cancellation comments.
Thanks for the love and the last but it's over.
Bitchiness it's not down there.
Yeah.
Oh there we go.
We go privacy.
But they do hide it.
They hide it a below the fold.
Yeah.
And then you just got to keep on scrolling down.
Oh for bitches.
Um,
and you know what's even pisses cancel account hose.
It's over.
My request has been sent.
You will receive an email shortly with instructions for confirming.
Yeah.
Why won't you just let me walk away?
That's what they're doing.
A divorce.
Now you have to go to your email and click on a link.
It's like a divorce.
So do it now because they don't want to,
they want to pretend they have more people on my street toward,
yes,
we had one on my space for a while until you did you end up deleting it?
No,
no,
I can't.
I tried to delete it.
They won't let him know he's fucks.
My space are so tricky.
Like,
yeah,
we'll get back to you with an email.
It's like a girl that you can never break up with.
Right.
I'll call you back and then we'll break up the pitch.
Never calls you back.
Okay.